you like Andrew Kate I feel like  Andrew's hey what do you like about him  I like his forwardness and I like that  he's trying to get people out of the  Matrix and I like the fact that he's  trying to remind men about masculinity  because it's really dying out in today's  world you're the first person that I've  spoken to today that actually likes  Andrew Tate one of the things that  everyone has an issue with is that he  said women are the property of men  what's your take it comes to  relationships I do believe that the man  prays a different role compared to the  woman I actually agree I think  because you're putting out a message  that most people in today's world try to  ignore I really appreciate you mate and  keep doing what you're doing don't give  up